should the American people prepare for a  recession no look they've been saying  this now how every every six months they  say this every six months they look down  the next six months and see what's going  to happen it hadn't happened yet it  hadn't been there there has there is no  there's no guarantee that they're going  to raise I don't think there will be a  recession if it is it'll be a very  slight recession that is we'll move down  slightly so just for the record we are  currently in a recession and no  politically correct leftist orwellian  wordsmithing is going to change that we  are in a recession the definition of a  recession is two consecutive quarters of  negative GDP growth that is what the  economists agree is the meaning of a  recession that's what Biden's economists  said is the meaning of a recession  before for political convenience they  tried to change their opinion when we  were in a recession that's what it is we  are in a recession